BUT FIRST, THE SHINY OBJECT OF
IMPEACHMENT, THAT IS THE FOCUS
OF TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
IN THE WAKE OF THE JOHN BOLTON
MANUSCRIPT LEAK, THE MEDIA HAVE
BEEN SALIVATING OVER THE
PROSPECT OF MAJOR G.O.P.
DEFECTIONS IN THE SENATE.
>> MITT ROMNEY, SUSAN COLLINS,
LAMAR ALEXANDER, AND
LISA MURKOWSKI.
>> THEY SEEM TO WANT WITNESSES
WHILE LAMAR ALEXANDER AND
LISA MURKOWSKI HAVE EXPRESSED AN
OPENNESS TO THE IDEA.
>> JOHN BOLTON AND
LAMAR ALEXANDER GO WAY BACK, I
GOT TO THINK THOSE MEAN
SOMETHING.
>> Laura: THINGS REALLY HIT A
FEVER PITCH AFTER THIS HEADLINE
DROPPED YESTERDAY, REPORTING
THAT MITCH McCONNELL DIDN’T
HAVE THE VOTES TO BLOCK
WITNESSES FROM THE IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL.
>> MITCH McCONNELL DOESN’T
HAVE THE VOTES TO BLOCK
WITNESSES WHICH HE IS DESPERATE
TO DO.
>> BLOCKBUSTER NEWS THAT
MITCH McCONNELL IS CRYING AT
LEAST FOR NOW, UNCLE.
>> MADE IT CLEAR THAT VOTES TO
BLOCK WITNESSES AREN’T LOCKED IN
YET.
>> HE KNOWS HE NEEDS A LOT OF
HELP NOW TO GET THOSE VOTES.
>> Laura: SPEAKING OF SOMEONE
WHO NEEDS A LOT OF HELP, AS WE
TOLD YOU LAST NIGHT, THE MEDIA
GOT AWAY HEAD OF ITSELF,
SUFFERING AGAIN FROM WISHFUL
THINKING SYNDROME.
IT NOT ONLY LOOKS LIKE
McCONNELL HAS THE VOTES TO END
THE CHARADE, HE MAY EVEN HAVE A
FEW DESPAIR.
>> MANY VULNERABLE REPUBLICANS
AT THIS TIME INSTEAD OF TRYING
TO MOVE TOWARD THE CENTER, THEY
ARE ACTUALLY PRIVATELY TELLING
THE MAJORITY LEADER, WE WANT
THIS DONE AND THEY WANT THIS
TRIAL OVER WITH.
YOU HAVE THE ENTIRE REPUBLICAN
PARTY EMBRACING TRUMP’S HIM AT
THIS CRITICAL MOMENT JUST MONTHS
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> Laura: FENCE SITTERS
CORY GARDNER AND PAT TOOMEY,
THEY ANNOUNCED THAT THEY OPPOSE
CALLING MORE WITNESSES AND
LISA MURKOWSKI MAY BE JOINING
THEM.
THE HILL IS REPORTING THAT IT
WAS CLEAR TO SENATE REPUBLICANS
ON WEDNESDAY AFTER A MORNING
MEETING BETWEEN SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER MITCH McCONNELL AND
SENATOR MURKOWSKI, THE QUESTION
OF HAVING ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IS SETTLED AND THE SENATE WILL
VOTE FRIDAY TO WRAP UP
IMPEACHMENT OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WITHOUT MURKOWSKI, DEMOCRATS
CAN’T GET THE FOUR VOTES THEY
NEED.
SORRY, AT LEAST YOU HAVE GREAT
HAIR.
DESPITE ALL THE EARLY
PREDICTIONS THAT REPUBLICANS
WERE FRACTURING, THE DEMOCRATS
ARE ACTUALLY THE ONES WHO ARE
FALLING APART.
>> SEVERAL RED STATE DEMOCRATS
ARE NOT RULING OUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF CLEARING
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE ULTIMATE
VOTE.
>> DEMOCRATIC SENATORS AND
STATES THAT TRUMP WON HAVE NOT
RULED OUT VOTING TO ACQUIT HIM.
>> JONES, MANSION,
KYRSTEN SINEMA COULD BE SQUISHY
ON SOME ASPECTS OF THIS.
>> Laura: SHOULD THE SENATE
VOTED TO HEAR WITNESSES, AT
LEAST ONE DEMOCRAT, JOE MANCHIN,
MAY BE SHIFTING AWAY FROM HIS
PARTY.
>> IS HUNTER BIDEN A RELEVANT
WITNESS?
>> I THINK SO, I REALLY DO.
>> WOULD YOU VOTE TO CALL HUNTER
BIDEN AS A WITNESS?
>> IF WHATEVER RULES IT AS
PERTINENT, ABSOLUTELY.
>> IF THE DEMOCRATS CALL
WITNESSES, SHOULD REPUBLICANS
HAVE A RIGHT TO CALL ALSO?
>> Laura: FACE WITH A
BIPARTISAN ACQUITTAL OF TRUMP,
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA ARE
RESORTING TO DESPERATE 11TH HOUR
SHE HOUR SHENANIGANS, HERE IS
THE LATEST FAKE NEWS FROM CNN’S
JAKE TAPPER.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS ISSUED A
FORMAL THREAT TO AMBASSADOR
BOLTON AND HIS ASSOCIATES TRYING
TO KEEP THEM FROM PUBLISHING THE
BOOK.
>> Laura: OH JAKE, THE FORMAL
THREAT IS IN REALITY A ROUTINE
LETTER FROM AN NSC LAWYER THAT
WAS SENT OVER A WEEK AGO IN
WHICH HE WROTE THE NSC WANTS TO
"WORK WITH YOU" TO ENSURE HIS
ABILITY TO TELL HIS STORY
WITHOUT DISCLOSING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
IS THAT REALLY SO THREATENING?
THERE IS THIS TINY DETAIL, THE
LETTER WAS SENT THREE DAYS
BEFORE "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTED ON HIS BOOK MANUSCRIPT,
DO YOU SEE WHERE THIS IS ALL
GOING?
AND THEN CAME THE NEXT SHINY
OBJECT FROM CONGRESSMAN ELLIOTT
ANGLE WHO CLAIMED THAT ON A
SEPTEMBER 23RD CALL, AMBASSADOR
BOLTON SUGGESTED TO ME
UNPROMPTED THAT THE COMMITTEE
LOOKING INTO THE RECALL OF MARIA
BONAVENTURE, HE STRONGLY IMPLIED
SOMETHING IMPROPER HAD OCCURRED
AROUND HER REMOVAL.
NOT ONLY IS THIS A SKETCHY
CLAIM, IT’S IRRELEVANT TO
IMPEACHMENT.
WE GOT TO DANGLE THE OBJECT.
OF TRUMP HAS THE POWER TO REMOVE
AN AMBASSADOR FOR ANY REASON,
THEY SERVE AT THE PRESIDENT’S
PLEASURE.
AS CRACKS SPREAD TO THE
DEMOCRATIC RANKS, WE PREDICT
THEY ARE GOING TO TRY TO PULL
OTHER RABBITS OUT OF THEIR HAT
BUT AT THIS POINT, REPUBLICAN
SENATORS SHOULD KNOW HOW THIS
GAME IS PLAYED.
JUST WHEN YOU THINK YOU SEE THE
LIGHT OF THE END OF THE TUNNEL,
THE RESISTANCE THROWS SHADE.
REPORTS OF NEW WITNESSES FLOOD
TWITTER, TARGETED LEAKS DOMINATE
THE NEW CYCLE, ANYTHING TO
PROLONG THE DRAMA.
>> EVERY DAY THERE IS NEW
INFORMATION COMING TO LIGHT.
WE KNOW THERE’S GOING TO BE
INFORMATION COMING TO LIGHT ON
MARCH 17TH WHEN THE BOLTON BOOK
COMES OUT.
THEY’RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE
REVELATIONS AND MEMBERS OF THIS
BODY ON BOTH SIDES OF THE ISLE
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO ANSWER A
QUESTION EACH TIME IT DOES, WHY
DIDN’T YOU WANT TO KNOW THAT
WHEN IT WOULD’VE HELPED INFORM
YOUR DECISION?
>> Laura: HE’S ADMITTING IT!
BOLTON HAS AN AX TO GRIND AND
BOOKS TO SELL, NOTHING HE HAS TO
SAY AS I SAID LAST NIGHT OF
CHANGE IS THE UNDERLYING FACTS
THAT WE HAVE PAINSTAKINGLY LAID
OUT FOR YOU OVER THE PAST FOUR
MONTHS NOW.
UKRAINE GOT ITS AID WITHOUT EVER
HAVING TO DO OR SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT BURISMA OR THE BIDENS AND
THE PRESIDENT WAS WELL WITHIN
HIS RIGHTS TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
UKRAINIAN CORRUPTION IN 2016 AND
PERHAPS MORE CORRUPTION COMING
DOWN THE PIKE IN 2020.
OUR FOUNDERS DIDN’T WANT US TO
DO IMPEACHMENT BY SHINY OBJECT
AND THE SENATE SHOULDN’T TORTURE
THE NATION ANY LONGER WITH ITS
TEDIOUS LEGAL DRAMA.
YET JUST AS THEY TRIED IN THE
KAVANAUGH FIGHT BY DIGGING UP
SUPPOSE THAT VICTIMS AND LATE IN
THE GAME UNVERIFIABLE
ALLEGATIONS, DEMOCRATS THINK
TIME IS ON THEIR SIDE.
REPUBLICANS FOUGHT THIS DOWN AND
THEY NEED TO FIGHT IT NOW.
THE ONLY RESPONSE TO THE
DEMOCRATS SLEAZY TACTICS IS
UNWAVERING G.O.P. UNITY.
AT LEAST FOR A COUPLE MORE DAYS.
AND ONE SCHIFF AND SCHUMER
ACCUSE YOU A COVER UP THROW IT
RIGHT BACK IN THEIR FACES, THEY
HAVE BEEN COVERING FOR THEIR OWN
DEEP STATE, THEIR OWN FOREIGN
POLICY AND DOMESTIC POLICY
FAILURES SINCE TRUMP ANNOUNCED
WAS RUNNING.
IN THE END, WHAT WILL THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE ACCOMPLISHED IN
THIS SHINY OBJECT IMPEACHMENT?
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ENJOYING HIS
BEST APPROVAL RATING IN THREE